bonjour bonjour monsieur roi merci de
nous recevoir où sommes-nous et pourquoi
c'est important pour vous le roi du
smoke sur Saint-Hubert il y a plus de 72
ans
avant de commencer le métier j'ai été le
dire
avec ma mère quand j'étais jeune parce
qu'on habitait à Rosemont j'aime bien
le matin de novembre neigeux Claude
Poirier nous avait donné rendez-vous sur
la Plaza Saint-Hubert dans une
institution de Montréal le roi du smoke
weed c'est ici entre autres qui la
rencontrer Richard Blas surnommé le chat
21 meurtres trois évasions de prison
un terrible incendie meurtrier au bar
Gargantua en 75
Richard Blas a été qualifié à l'époque
de criminel le plus dangereux du Canada
Claude Poirier a entretenu avec lui une
relation professionnelle disons
il était très rancunier porte facilement
puis je prie qu'un moment donné
il faisait pas le poids mais avec un
caractère qui avait c'était un
personnage
Claude Poirie a navigué pendant 50 ans
dans le milieu en cultivant son image du
gars de la rue aussi près des bandits
que des policiers trois générations de
Québécois le connaissent bien il a créé
son style inimitable le reste c'est
d'innombrables heures de travail il a
passion de métier qui était vue de haut
par les bien-pensants
quand j'ai commencé mon métier il y a
personne qui faisait ça à part de
Friends chez Jaro qui lui avait une
voiture identifiée puis couvrait les
feux de temps en temps mais il y a la
personne qui s'ouvre
des gens comme j'ai fait mon métier
pendant plus de partout la durée Claude
Poirier
on a on a été témoin de la retraite de
Pierre Bruno avec qui vous avez
travaillé beaucoup à TV entre eux qui a
duré des années dans ce métier là ce que
vous croyez que c'est finalement le seul
facteur qui compte quand on dit ça veut
dire quelque chose dans le ciel comme
mot de jouer dans le groupe baseball
dans la limite majeure mais pour rester
longtemps alors dans ce métier là j'en
ai vu passer il y en a beaucoup
malheureusement qui nous ont quitté
parce qu'ils sont décédés aujourd'hui
moi j'ai toujours dit crédibilité
contact et durée c'est ça puis couvrir
le fait divers ce qu'on a appelé pendant
des années
par certaines personnes qui se nabaient
c'est pas la Prestige d'être
correspondant à Québec Parlement Québec
ou à tabac moi je suis pas pierre Nadeau
je suis pas Bernard de Rome je suis pas
un patrice Roy je suis un gars que fait
son métier sur la fac mon université moi
j'ai pas été l'université mon père m'a
dit un jour ceux qui vont à l'université
c'est pour aller soit médecin ou prêtes
ou
avocats
travailler pour lui la journée j'ai dit
Théo je te laisse m'avoir faire de la
radio
ça a été la chicane chez ma mère avec
mon père puis moi parce qu'il ne pouvait
pas accepter ça puis je me suis dit mais
je vais me brosser une carrière mais
qu'est-ce que tu as fait
vous avez amené ce côté spectaculaire là
la voiture avec les résultats
on vous voyait arriver que l'autre
Poirier en fait vous arriviez avant tout
le monde quand j'ai commencé j'étais
vraiment pas le couple si jamais c'est
pas le cours qui faisait des étiquettes
alors je m'envoie le voir puis je dis je
m'en sers à ça ouais mais j'ai pas
d'argent je peux pas vous présenter j'ai
dû demander de l'argent j'ai dit moi je
vais travailler vous allez voir ce que
je dois faire alors pendant 9 mois ils
m'ont pas payé moi je gagnais 9000
pièces 2000 pièces à cette époque là en
60 pendant un mois une scène faisait mes
reporters des boîtes téléphoniques c'est
ma mère que je pratique
alors là
je fais de l'emprunt et j'étais
m'acheter une caverne blanche
avez-vous vu ce que j'ai fait en fin de
semaine puis de ça alors c'est le même
ça a commencé donc la passion du métier
vous l'aviez mais faites deux trois fois
vous dites les chiens écrasés c'était
vus de haut bah ouais par certaines
personnes
vous fasciniez à l'époque votre
personnage fascinait déjà là faut dire
une chose
non plus j'étais dans l'est de 10
paillettes les plus belles
déçu mais moi ce qui m'a aidé c'est mon
anniversaire tu vas faire 25 ans radio
les gens vont reconnaître ta voix mais
deux ans de télévision puis là les gens
vont identifiés ça ça m'a aidé quand tu
arrives sur une place parce que les gens
sont portés à aller voir des gens connus
toi Jésus quand tu vois sur le terrain
parce que en passant d'excellents
travail
on va parler à Patrice
s'amène avec son bitchologue prendre une
quant à n'importe quelle valise la
police savait pas est-ce que le fait
divers est mieux intégré aujourd'hui
vous pensez qu'il était est-ce que on
est moins snob parce que l'effet divers
ça dit quelque chose à sa société
d'ailleurs je dois dire moi je suis de
Radio-Can il y a encore cette école de
pensée chez nous des fois ça dépend
qu'on entend c'est des fêtes du vin en
fait divers ça dit quelque chose sur la
société
maintenant
ça fait divers un fait divers et c'est
sûr que une certaine époque on voyait
pas ça on pourra pas voir ça des caméras
aujourd'hui d'un palais de justice tous
les jours ils sont là autrefois là la
radio quand tu savais que il y avait un
événement majeur à Montréal si jamais
c'était sur les lieux moi j'ai connu la
période de ces jeunesse et il s'est
cassé il y a eu sec avait réussi vous
êtes à télémétropole au début c'est
croyez que vous fait entrer plus vous
avez la chance ou en tout cas l'habilité
de rester toujours à des antennes très
puissantes au Québec donc vous rentrez
chez le monde vous il y a trois
générations qui vous connaissent comme
si vous connaissez bien vous êtes encore
resté dans la rue c'est normal j'ai 84
pendant des années
la clientèle de jeunes m'a aidé quand
j'allais à prononcer des causeries dans
une université de parler de journalistes
c'est sûr et certain que les gens ils
aillent de voir puis regarde d'abord
c'est un moment donné il a une poussée
des questions sur 90 sur un tel je tiens
pas des héros parce que la plupart des
gens qui sont dans le milieu criminel
ils ont de la misère à se rendre jusqu'à
60 ans faites-en pas des héros si Claude
pour arriver affirme que les criminels
ne sont pas des héros il a par ailleurs
eu l'occasion de discuter avec plusieurs
d'entre eux et de les faire connaître au
grand public
il est l'un des rares journalistes avoir
pu s'asseoir avec vickotroni l'ex-cher
de la mafia montréalaise
la personne me dit vite 90 vues
mais vérifie des fois des informations
à qui elle appartient parce qu'il y
avait su que moi je voyais du serveuse
dans un restaurant qui a marié par la
suite un personnage important
en pleine guerre des motards Claude
Poirier réussi aussi approcher Maurice
Mom Boucher on se souvient de son scoop
puisqu'il assiste au mariage du Hells
René balloon Charlebois où Jean-Pierre
Ferland et Ginette Reno ont chanté c'est
curieux vous êtes d'abord un il faut que
vous soyez fasciné par la police puis il
faut soyez fasciné par le criminels
quand même je suis peut-être plus
fasciné par le milieu criminel que par
la police ces gars-là
malgré tout vous êtes fasciné puis comme
beaucoup de gens par ces gars memboucher
vous êtes le seul qu'il invite pour
prendre des photos quand il s'entend que
machine mais en même temps ce forum
antique c'est vilains
alors un jour j'ai appelé Bob ça va mais
bon ça va c'est effectué par sympathique
galant dans un restaurant d'aller le
rencontrer ce matin
[Musique]
je suis content je l'ai suivi prise
totale des fois ils ont joué y penser à
un moment donné il m'a invité à ce qu'il
y a des choses quand j'ai acheté au
mariage
les vierges en français les vierges
avancées
du centre-ville de Montréal des armes
illégales en circulation des fusils à
désordonnées des gangs de rue ce climat
d'insécurité dans certains quartiers de
Montréal que pense le vieux loup de ce
nouveau type de violence
Claude Poirier on dit depuis quelques
mois une année ou deux Montréal devient
plus violent et avez-vous l'impression
que le type de criminalité que l'on
assiste les gangs de rue plus ça tire
que c'est plus désorganisé que votre
époque
d'abord il y a plus de respect à
l'époque la mafia là dans la jambe a
fait des choses qui ont été fait depuis
quelques années où ça c'est fait ils ont
tué des dégâts de la mafia alors qu'il
était dans les soirées avec les enfants
dans la salle à manger
c'est plus que c'est
la GRC va vous dire quand Vito risito
était le parrain de la mafia il aille
gagner ça c'était un négociateur en paix
les gangs s'attendaient quand un moment
donné il y a eu la guerre des motards
vous arrêtez ça au ballon nous autres on
va s'en occuper
c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu la trêve au
Blue marine ça arrive Christine vous
avez été invité le seul aussi je vais
rentrer
aujourd'hui les gags de rue donc
violence plus
au hasard parfois on a l'impression que
c'est peut-être plus dangereux même il y
a eu le petit des rochers
qui est mort mais que ça peut arriver
encore aujourd'hui parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'il y a plus d'ordre il y
a plus de respect aujourd'hui les jeunes
de plus en plus ils sont armés mais moi
j'ai rien contre les jeux vidéo mais je
trouve que ça amené beaucoup plus de
violence que d'autres choses il y a des
jeunes qui vivent avec d'autres sortes
parce que vous en avez connu quand même
une période très violente à Montréal et
les les vols dans les banques prise
d'otage au Texas
vous êtes aujourd'hui c'est pire ou
c'est comment vous comparer ça avec
l'époque mais c'est plus dangereux
dans le nez
il y avait un contrat
animateur 24 sur 24 à
moi j'apprends ça la police m'appelle la
Sûreté du Québec me disait on veut
rencontrer au niveau bureau j'ai dit non
je lui avais vers
la station je travaillais à ces gamelles
pendant trois jours le matin je partais
de les dessert où j'habitais m'en aller
ça rigole
qui me suivait
aujourd'hui
défendait des motards
si vous savez vous ça devient j'arrive
pas à rien mais je veux savoir
en 2014 il quitte l'animation
quotidienne et le courriel il continue
de travailler sur des projets mais on le
sent il est difficile pour ce showman
même à 84 ans de quitter la scène
complètement
est-ce que c'est dur de quitter la scène
de d'être moins à l'avance pour vous
pour une personnalité comme vous qui
mordez puis que vous voulez être le
premier ou j'ai pas trouvé
autrement j'ai fait un poirier en quête
j'ai fait le secret judiciaire et que
vous pourriez j'ai eu l'occasion de
faire perron j'en ai fait plusieurs je
voulais ralentir des projets ici là où
vous avez le feu encore vous continuez
puis moi je travaille chez un petit
média ou à tous les deux semaines je
fais un commentaire sur différentes
choses il y a à peu près 40 000
personnes qui me suivent ils font des
commentaires judiciaire
[Musique]
la justice il y en a plus aujourd'hui il
y en a plus c'est un bon avocat
prud'hommes sa place publique s'arrêtait
une meilleure qu'elle aurait pu être là
ça aurait été le meilleur gars après si
normal que la Ville de Montréal a pas de
directeur de police depuis donc 12 mois
il faut un concours il faut un concours
pour trouver quelqu'un puis vous allez
continuer avez-vous encore une page
c'est le meilleur traitement que la
porte
vous avez de la santé là
[Musique]
merci